من بين الاف الاعداء الذين عرفتهم امريكا
وبريطانيا تاريخيا كان فريدس دوكين الاكثر
شراسه فهو ليس مجرد عميل نزي ادار حلقه
التجسس المانيه
فكراهيه للانجليز جعلته عدو اللدودا لهم
خلال اكثر من اربعه عقود فما قصته
وجدوا امه تحتضر في معسكراتهم فبدا رحله
الانتقام وجند عشرين رجلا لتخريب المنشات
البريطانيه قبل ان يوشى به ويسجن في عام
1902 افرج عنه وانتقل الى امريكا حيث عمل
صحفيا وتجنس كما استخدمه الرئيس ثيودو
روزفيلد كمدرب صيد في رحله موثقه لافريقيا
في صيف عام
1913 عرض دوكين خدمات التجسس على القنصليه
الالمانيه فيما كان في امريكا الجنوبيه
بحجه اعداد وثائقي عن رحله روزفيلد فمنح
لاسم الرمزي ضن وقام بمهمات لتعطيل
المجهود الحربي البريطاني كعمليه تفجير
سفن شحن بريطانيه واغراق سفينه اللورد
البريطاني هوراشو هاربرت كيتشنر الذي حمله
مسؤوليه تدمير عائلته على الرغم من ان
تقارير الطب الشرعي للسفينه لم تدعم ذلك
بالرغم من ذلك وحتى عام
1940 كاندوكين بارعا في الافلات من العقاب
لتجنب امريكا تسليم المجرمين الى بريطانيا
وبقي في نيويورك يشغل شركه للمحطات
الهوائيه في العلن ويبني حلقه التجسس كبرى
في الخفاء كانت الحلقه المكونه من 33 عضوا
تجمع معلومات حول سجلات الشحن الامريكيه
البريطانيه والتكنولوجيه العسكريه
الامريكيه
لكنها اكتشفت وحكم عليه بالسجن لمده 18
عاما لكنه خرج بعد 13 عاما بسبب اعتلال
صحته وقضاء اخر سنواته في مستشفى للرعايه
قبل وفاته عام
1956 رغم تكذيب بعض ما جاء به واعتقدوا
كين سيرته بكتاب الرجل الذي قتل كيتشنر
وذكر فيه فصولا مثيره جعلته احيا ان اسير
حرب واحيانا اخرى صياد العاب بالاضافه
لكونه صحفيا وجاسوسا لكن الدور الذي لم
يتخلى عنه هو العدو اللدود لبريطانيا